good morning Hank it's Monday you know
what that means special bonus video
coming to you in four parts part 1
Europe so Inc next week I will be on a
whirlwind tour of Europe with my wife
and a couple of my friends on Tuesday
June 16th we will be in Berlin for an
event that is unfortunately currently
sold out but nerdfighters of Germany I
will let you know on Twitter if more
tickets become available and regardless
I hope that you enjoy Margo Spearin my
German is excellent I know
then on Wednesday I will be in Paris
meeting and greeting people outside of a
bookstore more info in the doobly-doo
and on Thursday I will be in London at a
place and time yet to be determined the
appropriate Twitter feeds to find out
more are all in the doobly-doo but it is
starting to happen Hank the Paper Towns
movie is starting to become real part to
our podcast Hank our new podcast dear
Hank and John or as I prefer to think of
it Dear John and Hank has made its debut
on iTunes and SoundCloud links below
this week we discuss whether Bolling can
heal the broken human heart whether
people have peed on every square inch of
Earth and of course we have all the
latest news from Mars which is a cold
dead rock in the lifeless vacuum of
space and AFC Wimbledon the most
important soccer team in the history of
the universe part 3 the United States of
America Hank NAT and Cara and I will
also be touring in the u.s. in July but
I can't tell you where specifically
because I don't yet know we will be
visiting the states that get the most
votes over at Paper Towns movie calm /
tour there you can vote for your state
by liking and reblogging on tumblr one
tumblr note equals one vote and we will
visit the places that get the most votes
between now and June 15th
I think I'm just gonna be honest with
you I'm rooting for Indiana and Montana
although I will also accept any other
outcome part for the decoupling of wages
and productivity that's when people
really want to hear about in bonus
videos so Hank in your last video you
were like and I also worry about the
decoupling of productivity in wages as
it happens that's something I also spend
a lot of time thinking about so as you
can tell from this graph since World War
two wages and productivity were really
closely correlated until about 2000 when
there was this great decoupling and ever
since then productivity has surged but
wages have remained stagnant this is a
big part of why we've seen this dramatic
increase in the disparity of wealth in
the United States in the last like 20
years these days the richest 1% of
Americans control about 40 percent of
America's total wealth and
that's bad not just morally bad it's
also economically and socially bad
decreasing economic mobility means that
on average the most talented and
innovative people are less likely to get
the opportunities that they need in
order to create new businesses and make
lots of jobs and etc but anyway that
graph only goes back to 1947 if you go
back much further say to the Industrial
Revolution you see a similar decoupling
between productivity and wages which
this economist Robert Allen calls the
angles pause and the angles pause lasted
several decades until wages suddenly
shot up and it's possible I guess that
we're in the middle of another angles
pause because we are having this like
technological revolution right but it's
also possible that something entirely
different is happening because the
sample size of history is tiny like Hank
for almost all of the last 10,000 years
pretty much everyone's job was either
farmer or hunter-gatherer it's only in
like the last 300 years that lots and
lots of people had even had all of these
non-farm jobs that we associate with
wages and that lack of historical
precedence is a big part of the reason I
feel skeptical toward pretty much anyone
who expresses confidence when it comes
to fiscal policy or economic history in
shorting I think wealth inequality is
one of the biggest issues facing the
United States and I think we should be
very worried about the decoupling of
wages and productivity but we also need
to remember that we are in the middle of
history and we can collectively decide
whether this decreasing economic
mobility is permanent of course I might
be wrong the possibility that you might
be wrong is the very definition of
economics Hank nerdfighters I'd love to
hear more of your thoughts on this in
the meantime don't forget to vote for
your state at Paper Towns movie Comm /
tour linked in the doobly-doo and I hope
to see as many of you as possible next
week and Europe Hank you will see me
tomorrow